At least I'm a pretty good friend.
Looks like it's just you and me buddy
[screams]
Okay! Aright, we'll give you a little more time.
Oh God
I'm a clone you're not a clone for a
while we were content to not know
whether she was or wasn't I always felt
like yeah she's a clone which means that
there's a beth out there let's meet her
honey you're back you seem surprised you
never wrote and never exploded and then
he proceeded to lie to both his home
daughter and his space daughter about
which one is cloned he told me you're
the clone what do you think he told me
If one of you is still alive, you're my real daughter. If you're both alive, don't hurt the other one.
She's just a clone. She's not worth it. I'm comin' baby!
I wanted a version of Beth that was more
like Rick and therefore ironically hated
Rick I came back to kill him you know
I'd like to help.
Which Beth is real and which Beth is a clone you
jerks ready to get the answers to
your burning questions you know what
happened there that night I want you to
decide Beth turned around and locked
eyes with him and said tell me what kind
of daughter you would like me to be Rick's
response was to her and avoid the
entire conversation which is an ancient
Greek level of bad fatherhood and then
you can't bear to even know which one is
rich fake money fake money which is I
think the most cowardly part of it all
you literally don't even know which of
your daughter's is real of course you
don't you made a non choice and
committed to it really hard yeah
absolutely yeah you get no answers but
in effect I mean hopefully that's not a
dissatisfying thing because the answer
is one or the other the core of it is
finding Beth some solace with that and I
think the only solace she can find is in
there's none and being okay with that I
don't care what's in that vial yeah me
neither
I love having two moms I love having two
wives isn't the more important fact that
they both exist and the reason why they
both exist yeah I'm your piece of either
way
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Rick and Morty season 5
video for that post credit scene in the
teaser setting up the big story arcs
going forward in the more serialized
elements of the show so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos will do a new Rick and
Morty merch giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the season on
the video so just going down the list
starting with number 5 in the concept of
Beth's clone Dan Harmon in that video
says his original idea was that the Beth
at home should actually be the clone so
the real Beth is out there somewhere
let's meet her and see what happened to
her in wanting her to become the richest
version of Beth almost exactly like Rick
they kind of teased that back during
season 3 episode 9 when Rick gave her
the business and the big speech about
his philosophy on life and what she
could or could not do with herself the
truth is I'm not a good father and
you're exactly like me so this is the
Beth that became just like Rick I know
that a lot of theories about which one
is actually the clone and which one is
the real Beth there are actually a
couple different points of evidence that
sort of conflict with each other
according to Dan Harmon this Beth that
became like Rick should be the original
Beth but then during the episode they
try to shuffle at three-card Monte style
so that he doesn't know technically then
some of you that play the pocket Morty's
game have also noticed that this Rick
version of Beth is also being called
clone Beth in Pocket parties but
technically pocket Morty's isn't canon
to the show it's just like an extra game
that they play so you can't really use
the video game as evidence that this
Rick version of Beth is technically the
clone I would go more based on what Dan
Harmon's original intent was but
obviously they throw Rick under the bad
dad bus again because they also have him
try to remove all chance of knowing
which one was the clone and which one
was the real Beth within the logic of
the show the reason why he did that was
so that he could pretend to lie to
himself and he didn't have to take any
responsibility in the matter it's the
most non choice that he could possibly
make in that situation because if he had
fully chose which one was the clone he
knew that one day he'd eventually have
to destroy the clone so that the real
Beth could go on living because his
responsibility as a father should be to
his real daughter first
that was why when he was talking to
space Beth here he said that before he
was going to kill the clone he was going
to transmit all of her memories into her
body so that she would remember
everything that happened
while she was away but they kind of
tease during the episode they make this
space Beth think that he started to love
the clone more than he loved her the
original Beth but their intention with
the ending of the episode where both of
the beds just agreed to a truce in sort
of a co-living situation where they both
have a place at the head of the family
is them just making lemons out of
lemonade and trying to bond in their
hatred of their father then trying to be
better than Rick despite the fact that
they're both exactly like him as the
joke continues but because space Beth as
they call her during this video is the
cool mom she'll just continue to travel
around on adventures fighting the
Galactic government with her resistance
cell and future seasons and just
probably show up occasionally it just
depends on how often the writers want to
use her in adventures my assumption is
just based on how frequently they've
done canonical big serialized episodes
in the past which is not that frequently
we won't see her in a ton of episodes
they'll probably just bring her back for
the occasional really really big episode
throughout the rest of the series run
like maybe bring her back once during
season five then again during season 6
season 7 and so on right now going by
there 10 episodes per season in the 70s
ode renewal tour they got after season 3
Rick and Morty has ten seasons confirmed
that is a long time so that's the
biggest reason why all their episodes
aren't serialized real heavily like this
one here they're trying to make the show
work more like the uber long-running
shows like The Simpsons South Park
Family Guy they rarely do hard
serialization South Park out of that
bunch is probably the closest to doing
regular serialized episodes but they
kind of reset things at the end of each
season they do serialized arts within
the season but by the time you start for
a new season the kids are mostly back to
normal Simpsons and Family Guy that'll
probably keep going to the end of time
only have loosed serialized elements and
for the most part things go back to the
normal for their families at the end of
every single episode the main reason why
syndicated shows do stuff like this is
because animation especially performs
better sells better in syndication and
makes more money when you can watch any
random episode and follow the story
without having seen the previous episode
and you can't really do that with
heavily serialized shows like breaking
bad or Game of Thrones the Phoenix
person tag scene at the end seems like
the same kind of setup as the Beth clone
the
bring him back every once in a while
season to season without ever truly
killing him off also it's a multiverse
and they do dream sequences like the
story train episode so they do make it
difficult to say that they ever really
get rid of characters everyone press F
in the chat for squatchy I'm sure we'll
see him come back someday the whole joke
about the Jerry spin-off TV series with
the garbage truck is also one just a
funny tag scene because the spin-off
only lasts till it runs out of gas and
it's a silly premise to begin with but
it's also a reminder that they're
probably actually thinking about
developing official Rick and Morty's
spin-off TV series for Adult Swim every
successful show in the history of TV at
some point tries to develop a spin up
mostly so they can make more money
sometimes the spin-offs are decent and
most of the time they never truly
outlast the original show right now if
we're talking about possible Rick and
Morty's spin-offs that they could do at
this point it would be a show probably
about The Adventures of space Beth when
she doesn't come back to visit the
family then they could actually do the
big comic book crossover event series
thing where they have the huge adventure
together that covers a full hour of
story between the two shows they do it
every year with the DC TV shows on the
CW is a huge booster ratings they make a
ton of extra money so it'd be kind of
weird if they didn't eventually try that
with Rick and Morty there's still a
couple big serialized elements that they
didn't pick up on during season four
just kind of skipped over what about
evil Marty in the Citadel of Rick's yes
we did get that scene during season 4
episode 6 but because it was the story
trained technically it doesn't count
it was then making a joke about crazy
fanservice but if we're using that
episode is an example of what they would
and would not do they had a big Tammy
and Phoenix person scene during that and
if they actually did bring them back at
the end of the season then we can
logically say that they're still
planning on bringing back evil Morty in
the Citadel in a really big way who
knows that they'll keep doing the
emperor poopy butthole character too
because he wasn't around before season 4
if Dan and Justin are all about selling
more merch and toys they would probably
bring him back too because there's just
one more toy that they could sell but I
know you're all wondering what's going
on with the season 5 episodes what are
they going to be released well if they
can power through the rest of production
on the episodes that they're working on
right now at they'll drop at the end of
the year just like season for at least
the first half just
Roland is optimistic that they will be
able to get episodes out by the end of
the year Justin also said they've
already sent some of their episodes off
to be animated they have not recorded
voice over dialogue with the actors but
that happens pretty quickly so it's
pretty easy to get that out
they've already been hiring writers for
season six and started breaking the
stories for Rick and Morty season six
just to give you an idea for how far
ahead they're working but because of the
virus delays what's most likely to
happen is that we only get half of the
season at the end of the year just like
we did for season four and then the
other half next spring or if they can't
get enough of the episodes finished by
the end of the year they'll just hold
all 10 episodes till next spring early
sometime and just share all 10 episodes
without any kind of break in the middle
so we the way we get half of the
episodes at the end of the year and then
half next year or all ten early next
year for the most part those season five
will just be like season four mostly
one-off episodes and then a couple
serialized episodes throughout the
season but I will be doing Rick and
Morty season five bonus videos when we
get new information about the episodes
or they do interviews they do drop a lot
of teasers throughout the year so leave
all your requests in the comments below
and everybody just leave all your
theories about what they're going to do
with the season five stories but
congratulations to the hoop man you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Rick and Morty video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details everyone click here for
my full Rick and Morty season four
finale video and click here for my
brand-new Marvel phase 4 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!